let's talk about it right here from
timcast.com house passes bill to
decriminalize marijuana federally and it
was the republicans who said no
democratic rep jerry nadler passed with
a vote uh his bill sponsored by uh
sponsored by nether passed with a vote
of 220 to 204 along party lines
republican reps tom mcclintock brian
mast and matt gates joined the democrats
voting in support of the bill democrat
reps henry quail equeller and chris
pappas voted against it i'm i i would
really love to hear from thomas massey
why he is not listed among these
republicans did he vote against this
this is why i don't trust this stuff
right
when you hear it's like democrats want
to make it so that you can have pot and
then you hear that certain republicans
like thomas massey or margaret taylor
greene maybe not margin taylor green
she's more conservative thomas massey is
more libertarian but i'm like where are
the more libertarian voices matt gates
is voting for it it makes me feel like
it's probably not exactly what it is i
can guess why someone would vote against
this as a republican first of all mass
just followed me on twitter so congrats
to him for voting for the drug
legalizations um i think it's a very
dangerous slippery slope if the federal
government starts taxing things
that could be what they're concerned
about because that's not a thing i bet
that's it yeah and it's proposed that
they're gonna do a five percent sale i
think sales tax sales tax is a state
level so now you're going to have a
state and a federal tax just with one
product that is what i think would be
the big concern and it's i guess and to
be honest it's 483 pages which is
another reason it should be one page
yeah marijuana is here by leaving this
this is why i'm saying i don't trust
them and massey's good at finding a
thing in it that's like whoa you're
slipping this in i'm not voting for this
yeah he'll read it it's got stuff like
coming through puerto rico well the
other thing in the bill that i saw is
also it's retroactively um letting
people clear their records that's why i
want to wow
well donald trump as i stated should
have granted clemency and pardoned all
non-violent drug offenses that weren't
plea deal like they weren't down so
some people you know at first i was
saying like he should let all these
non-violent drug offenders go
um some people are like well what if
they sold the kids i'm like okay okay
okay that okay all right right there i'm
not sure right so not those people when
they said what if they did something
violent but took a plea deal
you're right
they should have a review process to go
through legitimate cases of someone who
was like charged with selling pot to
another adult or something and trump
should just get out of jail if they had
a gun on them can i just add one more
thing if you're someone who is on a
grand jury and the point of a grand jury
is the d.a or assistant d.a puts forth
the evidence and the grand jury says is
there enough evidence here to charge the
person and put them on trial our legal
system it's not your charge you have to
get those charges approved by a grand
jury if you're on a grand jury it is
very easy to convince those grand jurors
not to return charges on a drug charge
and there's nothing the district
attorney can do about it so this is your
ability if someone is a non-violent drug
uh salesman or whatever to get that
person off and save a life especially if
they're young and poor i don't think uh
here's the challenge and and this i
think it'll be a good conversation for
with you michael
are there some drugs that should be
illegal
i can't think of any what about like
fentanyl
well no the problem with fentanyl is the
dosing right right you don't it's not
like someone is taking fentanyl saying i
want to kill myself they think they're
taking let's say five grams and they're
getting 50 or that five grams is and
then your heart can't take and you die
so fentanyl was sold at doses that
people knew and understood in hospitals
yeah this would be this would be
resolved overnight
so then well this is why i ask right
because then you have the issue of what
if some guy is arrest is arrested for
selling let's say he's got 10 000 doses
of fentanyl and
let's say they're not misnumbered or
whatever and he dishes him out
throughout a city this person should not
be in jail or you know what do you think
that this person is pfizer
right you just described pfizer you are
that's true that's absolutely correct
what about are you think there's any
drugs that shouldn't be regulated
what do you mean by i think all drugs
should be related by the market the same
way that for example if you're jewish
and you keep kosher it's very important
for you that you eat food that is in
common with kosher law otherwise it's
like a major major sin and people don't
realize this but every food in the
supermarket has a little letter k that's
right and the k is not even strict
enough so the people who trust
the there's a u
that's the passover if you're really
strict you have to have a u not a k what
is this
the u is like a different kind of
licensing agency a rabbinical licensing
agency so what you would have is instead
of having it be the fda who is you know
largely corrupt and whatever you would
have just like right now at whole foods
you'll have fair trade or you'll stay up
i was on the plane just now and the
pretzels on the back said woman owned so
if that's something matters to you you
can look for that label i mean the
pretzels would not shut up and they were
really annoying but the funny thing
about that is when it's like woman owned
is that if you were a sexist you could
choose to discriminate against these
businesses whereas like if it's well no
the president's
like well i want more women cooking
women cooking they cost 80
they cost 80 as much as the mail on
pretzels uh michael how how could there
be a wage gap if there's no way to even
define what a woman is
that's a great point
who's making wages
so follow up on the question about
regulation um what
the fentanyl was about the dosing the
dosing so if people were just like i
don't there's no regulation on it and
the market dictates and he's like well
he's addicted to it so i can give him as
much as i want because the market's
dictating the guy's pocketbook is
dictating what he wants but it's an
addic a drug addiction sure
but what i'm saying is the problem with
fentanyl there's two issues or any
addictive drug it's the addiction but
also the oding and dying right and
that's the thing that's the first thing
to resolve and people not knowing dosing
so the more information that's out there
so people can make informed choices the
less people are going to be dying what
if it was regulated like like there's
there's a drug store that's got all of
the drugs all of them and you could
choose to do whatever you know but the
store couldn't give you an overdose
like you'd walk in and say i only buy
one dose at a time no like let's well
yeah well like aspirin imagine like that
what like you only buy one tablet at a
time no i well
what i mean to say is there's probably
different degrees to which it could be
regulated i'm not saying you know
necessarily you walk in and they say you
can only get one well they have that
this we don't have to guess about that
because we have that now uh tanning
salons you can only tan for x amount of
minutes so what they go do is they just
hit six tanning salons yeah and they
also have right now there's a workaround
for addicts where they go uh
prescription shopping so i'll have four
doctors give me prescriptions and then
i'll get them all filled so addicts the
thing that people need to appreciate is
addicts are really really good at
resolving their addiction and getting
workarounds they're good because their
entire identity and their entire world
view is about getting that drug so to to
pretend that they're going to be playing
by the rules as opposed to we have to
realize what we're dealing with and and
and kind of work to mitigate so let's
let's say the regulation is that
the the fentanyl for instance if it's
being sold by a private legal entity it
has the doses have to be measured
perfectly and isolated at single doses
yeah sure i think they would love that
yeah so so the reason i brought this up
is like if the problem is dosing well
street doses can be all over the place
but if there is a a formalized process
that the government's like hey if you're
selling these things you have to use
like a specific machine that guarantees
the dosage so that you can't give
someone the wrong dose but that's also
right now in california like if you go
to like dispensaries they can only be
like 20 milligrams tops so it's it's got
this weird kind of situation where
no but i mean like you'll you'll you'll
get uh a pill pack right like you will
for you know tylenol or whatever and
it's just like this is 25 milligrams of
drug this is 25 milligrams you're not
getting 75 26 40 exactly it's it's a you
know what that's what the market would
have there's no other there's no like
it's not like you go to buy vodka and
one bottle of absolutely it's going to
be 80 proof the other one's ten proof
they're all gonna be consistent but that
you you you can go and get you know it's
it's right the market does it yeah it's
a fraud issue but you needed a
prescription would you need a
prescription for the fentanyl then and
the people that can't get the person i
think that's the point i think the point
is you already can get prescriptions for
this stuff we're saying prescription
lists yeah personal choice to go and buy
whatever you want i feel like they would
just buy the 30 the 30 doses and take
two or three at a time and stuff yeah or
get someone to buy for them
easily i'm simply pointing out that you
might in the street get a pill that they
tell you for sure that would cut back on
that that's a big part of the problem
that's a big part yeah but
you're saying it sounds like you don't
even need regulation in that capacity
because why is the phone going yeah i
suppose the bigger threat is that
they're going to be shorting you they're
going to tell you it's a dose but it's a
half dose to save money yeah they're
going to be oh yeah yeah this is 20
milligrams well that's what you have
that's when you have branding because
then it becomes oh that stuff's weak
this is the good stuff same thing
without any other product yeah and then
like you know the thing with potato
chips like you buy the bag potato chips
is half air that's so annoying but you
know why that is right
it's not like they do it on purpose they
do do it on purpose dude i i settled it
doesn't settle that much i got an iced
latte at starbucks it was like 90
percent ice i got i sipped it i drank it
and it was gone and that's the fruit cup
of ice oh yeah it wasn't intentional
they fill the whole cup with ice and
then put the shot in the milkshake with
a little bit well to be fair
shrink-flation is through the roof these
days yeah you know uh it's really funny
someone people people are posting these
videos of like boxes of cereal
a week later and it's like they're just
visibly smaller but the funnier thing is
when the boxes stay the same size
and then you see the ounces on the
bottom yeah yeah it goes down i'm
concerned about fentanyl i feel like
it's next level like heroin was
dangerous but fentanyl
it's russia like crazy it's gonna be
that these guys ten times stronger drug
after family
and we're gonna be having the same
discussion but it's like you can only
take one hundredth of a percent of what
you could take have you ever had taken
opiates
one time yeah have you michael had
opiates yes uh sheamus no uh i would
describe it as a nightmarish drug i i
stretched on it because it's useful
uh when i had a kidney stone i was given
percocets and it was
a feeling so good it's indescribable
exactly yeah and that terrified me oh
yeah goodbye i was like wow i know
exactly why people get addicted to this
stuff
it it felt like it it it's hard to
explain it feels like all your joints
have become removed like if your body
was made out of like hinges like they
get all unhinged so it's like all your
body's just i see why it felt like it's
floating and yoga yeah yeah from i think
that was all kind of combined in the
early years i would describe it as like
it felt like a a
an energy of goodness emitting from
every part of my body are you big tim
cass sponsored by
sponsors
i'm literally saying it's terrifying for
that reason yeah and so you know what i
did even though more yeah
tossed them out wow you could have sold
those
or give it to children suppositories
yeah no no i i threw it i i i basically
tossed it into like a like i just pushed
it into i put on my windows so i just
threw in my cat's water and i was like
but then eventually i just was like i
don't want these things man because uh
uh
i got a power of pleasure
well it's it it it was it's it was scary
i'm like i completely understand why
people can get addicted to this stuff
because it just feels so good and you
think what's one more time to make it
feel and it's that second time when
things just and then it doesn't feel
good the second time it doesn't feel
bite is in the fourth bite you're like
i'm done with it that's like circus
peanuts yeah eat one you're like this is
great the second one is like please kill
me in my family
if we were gonna use opiates as a
species that's how we should use them
you take one bite and that's it you cut
yourself off after that if you can you
know leave it to the to the addictive
human to make a decision for themselves
drugs are bad okay
i don't know the word drug is very weird
what is a drug anyway this is a suitcase
term it's a non-food that you ingest
that doesn't like in your chemistry it's
like the word conspiracy like as soon as
you hear it you know it's bad but it's
like it's applied to things correctly
and incorrectly caffeine's a drug yeah
that's right it's psychoactive but those
are like lectured me about how caffeine
opened their mind you know
like hey man you gotta try it you're
gonna be like a different person not
true people often talk about how if they
don't have their coffee they can't think
they'll talk about how their coffee
makes them better but they won't be like
i'm enlightened because i had caffeine
they're not gonna say it they're not
gonna say i took a caffeine pill and i
met the machine elves yeah yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there